voilà un petit air de vacances
maintenant dans ce journal avec cette
balade aux antilles la semaine dernière
nous avions proposé deux sujets sur
s'est même senti une carte postale tout
d'abord est un sujet économique et
touristique
tous deux étaient signées jean françois
duval et henri lelièvre alors ce soir à
l'occasion de la visite à marseille
d'une délégation de la chambre de
commerce de la martinique
jean-françois nous allons parler du rhum
du rhum martiniquais et pour ça nous
avons donc invité mais jean-pierre bourg
de rien qui connaît très bien le sujet
puisqu'il est président d'une rhumerie
oui il est l'un des responsables et
surtout c'est à marseille et c'est ça
qui est important alors monsieur
bourdillon vous êtes très liées au
milieu marseillais vous êtes originaire
d'une famille marseillaise et parce
qu'il ya des liens assez étroits entre
marseille et les antilles nous allons le
voir dans un instant vous êtes venu là
avec une délégation pour essayer de voir
comment fonctionnaient les chambres de
commerce en métropole 2 particulièrement
celle de marseille et venant découvrir
votre entreprise s'était filmé il ya
quinze jours
mais cette rubrique du domaine de la
money c'est à quelques kilomètres de la
maison natale de joséphine de
beauharnais s'est installé au milieu des
champs de canne à sucre
cela emploie à peu près 200 personnes et
la distillation est de l'ordre de deux
millions huit cent mille litres par an
dont 70% sont consommés sur place on
boit beaucoup de roms à la martinique
un peu comme du vin rouge en provence
avec une augmentation sensible de la
consommation en métropole c'est une ré
un exemple réussi de relations
économiques entre la martinique et
marseille vient de voir que marseillaise
directeur régional et général que l'on
voit ici lui s'est très bien adapté à sa
situation qui ont établi des liens
d'amitié avec certains de leurs clients
et c'est bien d'inviter certains cas
comme celui qui me concerne c'est arrivé
à un tel point qu'il ya eu une
association donc une famille
marc gicquel et belloni qui avait une
entreprise de l'implantation de
commerces de gros et parallèlement une
distillerie de rhum ils se sont donc
associés avec la came bourdillon et ont
créé la société actuelle ici vous êtes
directeur commercial est ce que le fait
d'être marseillais donc dans une dans
une ville qui par tradition et ouverte
sur le monde ça vous a aidé ça m'a aidé
la mesure où vous connaissez déjà là le
commerce avec les amplis donc je
connaissais un petit peu là la mentalité
locale puisque si vous voulez la
première qualité d'un commerçant c'est
de s'adapter à ses clients et donc je
connaissais déjà un petit peu ses
clients antillais et ça a certainement
facilité les choses pour moi neurones
que l'on fabrique à alamo nice et du rob
agricole c'est-à-dire du rhum qui fait
remonter à partir du jus complet de la
can et non pas simplement de la mélasse
et cela s'explique tout particulièrement
en france
mais au niveau 2 des entreprises
métropolitaines elle même lorsqu'elle
apportent leurs produits vers un
martinique ça rentre dans le cadre de
leur service exportations et même les
sociétés qui n'ont pas de service
exploitation s'adresse à quelqu'un
d'autre pour faire cette exportation
donc le la martinique est temps pour la
métropole un territoire à l'exportation
réciproquement la métropole pour noé
territoire à l'exportation
voilà je voulais dit tout à l'heure pas
loin de 3 millions de bouteilles chaque
année avec monsieur bourdillon des
ventes qui monte en france très
régulièrement combien de bouteilles
vendues c'est à dire mais c'est assez
délicat de vous livrer ce secret enfin
disons que pour 1995 84 nous allons
atteindre à peu près le million de cols
alors qu'est-ce que les martiniquais
peuvent venir chercher à mars et quel
genre de relations économiques ou ton
établir entre cette île des caraïbes et
notre port d'abord vous savez que
marseille a quand même une vocation
d'exportation sur les anciens
territoires où les actuels départements
d'outre-mer et il était tout à fait
normal que la chambre de commerce de
martinique viennent un peu voir ce qui
se faisait dans cette métropole
marseillaise parce que nous sommes quand
même il faut pas l'oublier une petite
île nous avons peu de peu de moyens et
il faut retirer de toutes les chambres
de commerce métropolitaine
chaque chèque activités sur lesquelles
ces mêmes chansons sont tout à fait
pointu à marseille nous avons été
fortement impressionnés par le cnc y ait
ensuite aussi par leur centre de
formation professionnelle qui sont tout
à fait adaptées aux entreprises
malheureusement nous n'avons pas senti
que la chambre de commerce de marseille
veut y exporter ses cadres vers des
départements d'outre-mer comme les
nôtres et c'est bien dommage parce qu'il
est tout à fait intéressant d'aller
s'installer dans cet appartement
le climat est doux les affaires sont
encore possibles et serait souhaitable
aussi de former des gens à s'expatrier
dans un département jeux vont dire merci
c'est un appel qui croient qu'ils auront
entendu